hello and welcome to another matplotlib
tutorial in this video I'm going to be
teaching you all how to make live
updating charts and graphs with in that
plot live depending on what kind of work
you do having a live updating charts and
graphs can be pretty ideal and I know
that whenever I'm stirring trying to
figure out how to make this happen it
was pretty much not taught by anyone so
I had to go to the documentation to
figure it out so at least for me what I
was doing was trying to stream stock
prices and then have it kind of change
obviously with new prices but then you
could also you can change more than just
like the line right you can change
everything in that whole figure so I
made it so like the spines and the tick
labels of the graph would change
dynamically based on signals sent from a
price or sentiment on my end so the
lines basically around the chart right
would change to green if you know
there's a positive signal or change to
red if there was a negative signal and
so on so so it's obviously a bunch of
uses that you can do not just have a
line be live but also you can change the
entire chart dynamically so pretty cool
stuff so any way to do this the only
thing that you really need is matplotlib
I'm going to assume that most of you
guys have map plot live already but if
you don't I will link to the some
windows binaries for Python extensions
or you can go to matplotlib
org and go to their download and
download whatever version you need so if
you have any issues downloading power
matplotlib rather let me know I'm just
going to assume most people watching
this specific video probably already
have matplotlib either coming through my
series coming through their own stuff
and finding it by you know typing and
how to make live Python charts with
matplotlib or you're coming from my
charting tutorial either way you
probably have it so I'm not going to
waste your time with that so once you
have matplotlib you should be all set I
do suggest that you watch the other
videos here with matplotlib but you can
actually start this tutorial pretty
fresh even if you have not ever used
ma'am front lip so that will be okay and
eventually what I'm going to do is tie
this the live updating charts to our
pre-existing charting in Python tutorial
series so we'll pull live prices from
Yahoo's API in the there are like five
minute open high low close prices every
every five minutes are updated so I'll
show you guys how to do that and and
then obviously you could if you have
your own streaming prices you can tie it
into wherever you have streaming prices
so cool stuff ahead let's go ahead and
get started probably the only thing I'm
going to do in this video is show you
guys the documentation for what we're
going to do if you come over to
matplotlib a mat lab is like that it's a
it's a lot bigger than I think most
people realize at least more than I
realize it's kind of like Python you
know you think you know a lot in Python
until you start learning about all the
stuff you don't know in Python
anyway matplotlib org slash API slash
and when you come here we're going to be
interested in this animation function
but you can't look through like all of
this stuff there's all kinds of really
cool stuff in here and each one has a
bunch of stuff so like an animation
we've got all this all these various
things that you can do with an animation
what we're interested in is passing a
function through so if you just type in
func
you probably find it here we go what
we're looking at is this animation dot
func animation so this is going to let
us do is pass a function through these
this animation functionality within
matplotlib so we're going to pass
through a function that each time it's
going to look for new prices if it finds
them it will do that also within that
same function we can do all of the stuff
that we were talking about before like
dynamically changing colors you can even
have it dynamically change the zoom or I
mean just anything right like you can
put anything you want in that function
so it's really really cool so that's
what we're going to be doing obviously
in here the only thing that we're really
in you need will tell what figure will
tell it the func
in and that's pretty much it well so
we're also going to have a refresh time
in there and so on so anyway that's what
we're going to be doing in the next
video so if that sounds interesting
stick around and we'll probably get out
our first live updating chart in that
next video so as always thanks for
watching thank you for all the support
the subscriptions and until next time